i gotta figure out how to teach every
single girl to code that's how the
world's gonna be a better place
founder of ceo of girls who code
best-selling author reshma
i was often bullied at school our house
would get spray painted go back to your
own country and my mother just takes a
look at me and she's just crying and i
remember thinking
i will never
be silent so i ran for congress the new
york times finally acknowledged my race
and they sent a reporter they were
knocking on doors we had young girls
having my poster up she then decides to
write a story about my shoes
i'm not buying into that [ __ ]
i wasn't gonna let failure break me when
i started girls with code point four
percent of girls were interested in
coding and then we ended up with ten 000
girls who code clubs and then we
exploded in india and in the uk and
girls were interested
in making the world a better place
in building girls who code tell me about
the other side you know at the same time
i was trying to build girls who code i
was trying to have a baby i had more
miscarriages than i can count
i think when you are a social
entrepreneur and you're building
something the work is never done and
it's always at the sacrifice of others
for me i got that really wrong
really wrong so what advice would you
give to people who are probably veering
towards another rock bottom in their
lives
i think
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
reshma
i am as i was reading through your story
it reminded me of a quote that i read
many years ago and i i saved this quote
in my bookmarks and twitter and so i
went and looked for this quote when i
knew you were coming here today and it
and it somewhat resonated with me in
terms of your story the quote is my
parents were tasked with the job of
survival and i was self-actualization
the immigrant generational gap is real
what a luxury it is to search for
purpose meaning and fulfillment
and i know you came at least your
parents came here from uganda
take me back take me back to your
childhood and the context in which
you were
molded yeah well my parents escaped the
dictator idiamine in 1973
they changed their names from
mukund and madhu to mina and mike
because i think a recruiter told my dad
that the only way he was going to get a
job as an engineer instead of he was
working as a machinist in a factory was
to change his name
i think about them often because i can't
imagine in my 20s
coming to a new country
leaving your entire family or having to
leave your entire family not having a
single person that you know not knowing
the language and having to build a life
for yourself
and they did it um
you know they did it with a smile
they never really complained about it
and then everything became about giving
us the life
that they had sacrificed so much to have
when you have parents that come from
that background um
as you've written about
what they want for you as a child tends
to be centered on
you being able to survive in the world
and you wrote that when parents have
might have been a quote you said when
parents have lots of resources they care
more about you following your passions
but when they're like first generation
immigrants they care about you also
getting into a career where your
survival is guaranteed yeah what did
they want for you at that age and what
did you want for yourself you know i
think they wanted me to be you know a
doctor a lawyer or an engineer
and they wanted me to have a career
where i could you know
be upwardly mobile right for them it's
always about like okay if we're making
40 000 a year i want you to make 80. you
know i want to do better than i'm doing
um but so much about steve was about
drawing in the lines
you know not calling attention to
yourself you know i i was a very
different child
you know i led my first march when i was
13 years old
and you know i think there was a moment
i talk about this sometimes you know we
grew up in this very white working class
family in the midwest
and i was often bullied at school
and my mother was you know harassed for
wearing a sari at the kmart you know our
house would get teepeed or spray painted
go back to your home country
i remember this one day
some kids literally spray painted on the
side of her house you know go back to
her own country
and i woke up that morning my father was
sitting you know with you know
a jar of clorox
and he was just quietly cleaning
the side of the house
i think he was like humming a bollywood
tune
and i remember
watching him and thinking
i will never be like him
i will never
be silent
i will never not fight
and for him you know i think that that
was the task that you had to pay to be
in this country and i and and i think
there's so many
microaggressions or just obvious racism
that he faced in the workplace you know
opportunities he didn't get the name
calling all of it he never talked about
it never made him angry
and i think part of that was about
making sure that we had a different life
you know i have the story that you know
i've told before but the last day of
eighth grade you know it's a big
celebration there's been this girl that
had been harassing me the entire time at
school you know calling me names you
know back then they would call somebody
a [ __ ] as a derogatory term for somebody
who was brown
and so she called me this name and she
said and you know she basically
challenged me to a fight and instead of
saying
no or ignoring her i was like all right
i'll meet you at the back of the
schoolyard
and i remember right at the end of the
day the bell rings my best friend food
was like just get on the bus just get on
the bus and i'm like no i don't know
what it was maybe it was the last day of
school
but i show up to that schoolyard and the
entire schoolyard is just full of kids
and everyone's screaming and there's
spray paint and confetti
and she just comes up to me and bank
and then her friend has you know a
baseball bat
and i basically get beaten up
badly
with a tennis racket and a baseball cap
and i came to my friend who god bless
her
drags me home
and i remember walking in and my mother
just takes a look at me and she's just
crying and she's looking at my father
why'd you bring me to this country why
did you bring me to this country she
said that she says that
and they don't call the police
they don't call the school
they're just crying
and i am like i have like a concussion
you know i and the next day is my eighth
grade graduation
and my sister reminded me she said you
woke up the next morning and you look at
mom and dad and you say i'm going to
graduation
and i have this beautiful
blue lace dress
and my sister called her friend over who
like did my makeup
and again we go to graduation my father
i think finds the parents the parents
just they laugh and say kids are kids
and again my mother cries why did you
bring me this country
but you know that was a
a shift
in myself because i think up until that
point i was trying to be white
you know i was mad that my parents made
me reshma instead of rachel you know i
was mad that i sometimes smelled like
indian food you know i was mad that i
couldn't go to church and know what they
were talking about that we believed you
know in krishna instead of jesus and at
that moment everything shifted
and i realized that i'm not white
i'm i'm never going to be accepted
um and so i better be proud of who i am
and i better fight for who i am and for
people like me if i removed that
experience
from your history what would i be
removing from your character oh my god
everything everything i
i am i think 100 of who i am from that
moment um
again i think a year later i led my
first march i started my first
organization called prism prejudice
reduction interested students movement i
got better at naming organizations the
older i got but that's when i became a
warrior
you know that's when i became
a fighter and so i'm so grateful
to have had
that trauma
because it's made me who i am but i will
be honest i don't think i have fully
processed it
um i don't i don't remember i don't like
relive that moment until other people
who were there like do you remember that
app like even my sister reminding me
that i woke up the next day being like
do you know that you said that you're
gonna go to graduation like i don't
remember that so i i still do think that
even though these experiences are
transformative
um
they are
they're painful
you know right now we're going through
in new york city this you know all of
this asian hate
and all these hate crimes that are
happening
against asian americans in new york city
and across the country
and as they've been happening i think
i've been thinking about this stuff
because i was like one day i was like oh
i can count the amount of times
literally and that's sad that you can
count the amount of times that something
has happened to you hateful or violent
um
but i think part of surviving is about
sometimes blocking out these moments or
rewriting what they meant to you
in the future
but in the past it was painful
but in the future it can be empowering
it can be inspiring because you can tell
the story and you can you can you know
it fundamentally changed me i don't
think i would have built the movements
that i'm building right now i don't i
don't have that i can feel
pain i know what it's like to be
um
not accepted to be ostracized to be
hated
and when you when you got into the
working world after university you went
to yale right yeah at three times after
i finally got in oh really oh i was
obsessed
you tried to get in three times yeah try
to get in three times
i again you know grew up in a
working-class community nobody went to
yale harvard
i joke that there's some like indian
auntie you know at the temple that
talked about some kid but i never met
them
everybody went to community school state
school i didn't even
know how i would apply i don't think i
ever applied to university
but i knew from a young age that i
wanted to do something
and i knew that i lived in a country
where credentials mattered especially as
a woman of color and that if you had
that yale or harvard degree
people were gonna
believe in you
or at least open some doors
and that was always my from the time i
was 13 years old going to yale law
school was always
the thing i was chasing
is so i had an argument with some a guy
on twitter one day he's actually a
friend of mine and i've always because i
dropped out of university went for one
lecture not for me left
and
he made the case to me which sounds very
similar to the case you've just made to
me which is as a sort of a an immigrant
getting that stamp from one of
universities is one way to kind of get
security around your future and because
i was kind of in the camp that most
university degrees are actually a huge
amount of debt which you become like
encumbered with and then you get very
little in terms of delivery versus the
amount of debt and time it takes to get
that degree and that there's other ways
but he made that point to me that for
immigrants
in fact getting a
that stamp or that certificate is
actually
um one way that they can secure their
future what was your stance on that yeah
i mean i think it's a credential i don't
know how much it matters now like now
when i hire people i want to know about
your grit your hustle like how you work
um your work ethic less about where i
don't even think i know we're half the
people who work for me go went to school
nor do i pay attention to it any of them
um but i think when i was growing up it
did matter but i will say
that
being in those kinds of institutions i
often would just sit in my chair and
watch
watched at how people with power
navigate
and i think that that then taught me a
lot and i would say it's on the boards
that i sit on today you know a lot of it
is just
watching how people operate and how
people navigate you know going to yale
law school i i i said it i never could
raise my hand
because all these kids had gone to these
fancy private schools and i don't know
what they were talking about and i felt
i felt like i didn't belong
and so
that's the bad part of it right because
you feel like
you kind of snuck in and you're not able
to fully step into your power and
articulate and be who you want to be
um
but i think it was a really
powerful experience for me
in grit because again i kept applying i
kept applying i kept applying i kept
applying and i finally transferred to
your law school and got in and got that
degree now do i think i would still be
the same person
if i didn't have a degree for meal in a
master's degree from harvard yeah
because at the end of the day like it
wasn't those things um that made me who
i am today
you leave with 300 000 in debt a lot of
debt that is ridiculous yeah i blame my
father
in our in the uk we don't get that much
debt we get
50k if you'll you know do badly but you
know that's that's probably the top end
but three hundred thousand dollars in
debt when you join the working world
that forces your hand a little bit when
you're in the working world right in
terms of the the jobs that you can take
because you need to pay that off totally
force my hand
yeah because i would have liked when i
graduated to go be a civil rights lawyer
but instead i get an offer from a fancy
law firm where i'm making
you know a couple thousand bucks a month
and i didn't do the math on the interest
payments you know or how long it would
actually take for me to pay off this
debt because that was just that was just
principle in that interest
and now you know basically 23 years
later i'm still paying it off
but i think that we're we're
that's why i think so many people who
actually want to make a difference
because they have student loan debt
aren't able to and then wait and wait
and wait and you see all these good
ideas kind of die on the vine because
now you're stuck working for the man
and you literally feel stuck
and you don't know how to get out how
did you feel oh i was miserable i mean
because that wasn't the plan you know
the plan when i graduated law school was
you know to run for office and and i
would just go take this law firm job and
after a couple years i would quit and go
do the thing
but then i got stuck because i there now
i was helping my parents with you know
some of their finances i was living this
very i had this apartment that i had to
pay rent for and i was then living a
life
that you know saddled me to that desk
and i was getting older
and then 10 years passed by
and i don't know about you but for me i
i i rise like a phoenix from the ashes
and what i mean by that like is i have
to be at my bottom
of like anxiety depression despair and
then i make a change
and i really did find myself you know at
age 33 like every night barely being
able to get out of bed you know and
having a large glass of wine and just
crying
because i was like is this my life i you
know they say in hinduism like
you have a dharma like what you're put
on this earth to do
and i feel so blessed that from the time
i was a little girl i knew what my
dharma was i remember just laying on the
grass looking at the clouds
and just imagining this life
of being a change maker
of making a difference in the world and
here i was 2008 the world is falling
apart and i'm sitting in the freaking
hedge fund as a lawyer like what
i'm so far away from that little girl
who's staring at the clouds and i didn't
know how to get out
from this life that i felt very stuck by
because i wasn't rich i didn't have all
this money in the bank account and i did
have also i think the expectations of my
immigrant parents because i was doing
what the good indian girl was supposed
to be doing i was a lawyer in a law firm
and nobody i knew
had the path that i wanted to take so i
didn't even know how to get there
and you know i didn't know who to ask i
didn't know who was going to give me the
playbook
and so i was lost
and
i
i remember i had a one of my best
friends deepa
happened to call me
at this moment and she just said
just quit
and there was nothing like profound but
there was something about i think
hearing those words at the right time
in my life that was like yeah i can just
quit like i can and i did and the second
call i made was to my father
and i remember him saying beta
yes quit
and then i was like whoa
like
because i had built him up
as the reason that i was not chasing my
dreams
and by getting that permission i
realized oh i was the one it was my fear
you know my fear of like making taking a
risk
that was actually standing in the way of
me actually doing what i was meant to do
um so then i didn't have any more
excuses
and i ran for congress
isn't it amazing that we
most of us especially i think kids of
first generation immigrants
end up trying to live out our parents
dreams and then the other thing is this
kind of miscalculation of risk i contin
i continue to hear about and that i kind
of faced in my own life that we believe
the risk is
not fulfilling
the external expectation whereas it's so
evidently clear from every person that
i've sat here with that the actual risk
if you just zoom out ends up being
not following
the dreams of that girl staring at the
stars that actually is the risk in fact
the courageous thing to do the most
risky thing to do is to stay in the law
firm because you're risking the most
important thing of all your happiness
yeah and if you can like refrain that
and understand that like i say this
sometimes to when i meet young people
and they're in jobs they go you're the
risk takers
i'm not i'm the coward
i couldn't take the risk you guys are
taking and i think if you just reframe
it which is clearly what your life has
proven to be it's proven that the
biggest risk was actually staying yeah
it can be a really liberating force and
off you go you run for congress which is
a
tremendous thing to do
yeah crazy thing to do i was 33 i was
the first
south asian american any american woman
to run for congress in the united states
i had no idea what i was doing like i
said like i didn't have i couldn't be
like hey dad you know you build me a
campaign strategy or
and i had to kind of figure it out on my
own and um
also like people i mean
i ran against this very powerful
uh very vindictive
um woman
who
you know was not was not someone who was
going to take lightly to this young
brown girl
running against her for her seat did she
criticize you smoothie oh my god still
but still yeah she hasn't really gotten
over it still but
in some ways though it was it's good
because i it wasn't an easy thing to do
meaning it wasn't it'd be much easier if
the seat was open or if the other person
was like this is great you know we have
competition in the race but
i really it was it was such a beautiful
experience because i was so damn naive
like i really thought that i could shake
every hand
meet every voter
um and i would win but it was the best
the best experience of my life because
it's how i learned how to be an
entrepreneur because you know when you
run a campaign it's like starting a
business and shutting it down in the
span of 10 months
you got to hire people
you know you got to raise money you got
to figure out what your message is what
your brand is it's exactly what taught
me that experience is what taught me to
build grocery code and martial land for
moms um and what gave me probably the
confidence to do it you had to walk into
rooms i mean i had to walk into rooms of
like you know 65 year old seniors who
couldn't even pronounce my name who had
asked me where religion was right
it was wild
and i never went on television before my
first tv interview was chris matthews
which was the largest news time show he
was so mean to me i didn't even know
where to look in the screen it was a
mess um
i didn't know how to dress
i had never given a like a speech in
front of people before i remember i
would like literally practice my speech
and memorize it and pace my little
apartment you know
and and so everything was just um
scary but in
amazing it was the best
best still probably the best 10 months
of my life
when you make that decision to run for
public office and that per person starts
criticizing you probably quite
personally probably quite based on
character that's the best way to i think
discredit a political opponent how does
that actually feel in in the moment
because especially reflecting on your
childhood yeah it was devastating
because i was um well you know first a
lot of you know incredible feminists
like geraldine ferraro were like
trying to get me as gloria stein and was
like why are you running like these are
women who i
admired
um because again i think when you
and i i thought
i would go to these you know campaign
events and people would say well young
people need to run
young women you should run for office
one day
and i naively thought well look i'm
running like aren't is there you know
isn't that am i doing what you we've
been talking about with the movement
needs but really what they meant is like
run but don't run against me
and don't run against one of us
and and also i think the second part of
my story was very inspirational being
the daughter of immigrants
you know
coming from working class background so
they really had to shift my narrative
and she did a really good because i came
from
wall street you know i wasn't running
wall street i was you know a lawyer a
junior lawyer at wall street but so that
narrative shift happened and because i
had never
known how to control my own narrative
i lost that battle
and i often found myself on the
defensive
and and people are mean
and i would make the mistake of reading
the comment section
and um
and
it was really really tough
really tough
and i never got the i never got to be
the person that i was you remember this
one time that we finally got the new
york times to do
you know a story on our race and i had
now
i was this brown girl i had raised more
money
than any democratic challenger i was
actually the only
democrat i was the first democrat
challenger many ways in the in the
history now it's very common you know
alexandria ocasio my friend right it's
back then it was like never done so i
was like this upstart you know that was
making waves in in many ways i think
helped open the path up for people like
alex to actually say yeah we got to
fight the establishment
but i remember the the last the last
week the race the new york times finally
acknowledged my race and they sent a
reporter and she followed me around the
whole day we're knocking on doors and
immigrant communities were walking into
like you know communities in queens
where you had young bangladeshi girls
having my poster up being like i want to
be like her one day
and how revolutionary it was especially
for the community to see someone who
looks like them
running for office
and i remember she then decides to write
a story about my shoes yeah [ __ ]
yeah
not a word about my campaign but about
my shoes
and it was you know
again such an example of of what we do
to young women young people of color
when they run
you know we make it uh a caricature
we don't take them seriously and then
people don't take them seriously i lose
like spectacularly um
and i was shocked that i lost
uh i had not even written my concession
speech we had booked this hotel room in
new york city that we could not afford
and my campaign organizers had posted
the entire room with all these notes i
can't wait to be in washington this is
the bill we're going to pass this is the
change we're going to make
i had literally because what happens
when you're
when you're running for office you go to
these you know new york city subway
stops
and you hand out your campaign and
everyone was like i voted for you i
voted for you i voted for you so i was
like i got this and the bag you know
like it's gonna be you know
an upset
and then i'm sitting there my father's
you know kind of sitting with me and
we're watching the election returns come
in
and like you know five minutes in it's
done my dad's like i'm going to bed i'm
like thanks dad
um
and i wanted to cry
so bad
i was devastated
and you know i had no contingency plan
and i literally picked a fight
with some very powerful people
and i remember there's this young woman
who
every morning was like with me and you
know she was my she was like my you know
basically my body person as they call it
she's just looking at me
rebecca and i was like i'm not gonna cry
because i know she's gonna remember this
moment for the rest of her life
and i need to show strength
and so
i stood up there in my victory party
everybody's crying the entire place is
crying i'm standing there and i'm just
like you know gotta do it again don't
you worry and then i came back to my
hotel room and then i cried
and cried for like a month
and how did you pick yourself up from
there
and rise from the ashes once again to
found girls who code and sort of i guess
karen
carrying on with your life
uh drinking a lot of margaritas
no but seriously i think um
i've read a lot about competitive
athletes and
for a lot of them what makes them great
is they had
something that happened in their career
early on
they didn't get picked in the first
draft
you know they missed that one shot
and it puts kind of a chip on their
shoulder like i'm going to show you
and that's what this brace did for me
it was like i didn't get picked in the
first draft
but i knew what i was
what my potential was
and i was going to show you and i wasn't
gonna i wasn't gonna let failure break
me
take some time to get to that place
right
the dust has got to settle the tears
have got to be cried and then it took me
a month yeah but i also have a hack on
failure that has worked for me which is
i let myself ruminate about it you know
then talk to my boyfriend now my husband
a million why'd that happen what mistake
did i make you know my father sent me a
nice long email about the 10 things i
did wrong really um
brutal listen
indian parents you know what i mean
um
and then i was done and i said and i was
ready to move on and started thinking
about what i was going to build next the
campaign maybe that i would run for next
um so the first
i think
for me the first
that was my first really big failure
and i think sometimes the first one is
easier because i i kind of could tell
myself well i did make some mistakes if
i did that differently
if i you know hired that person if i
didn't say that then maybe i would have
won so my first campaign loss was was
easier than my second one
also understand the system the second
time around right so like the first time
you're actually learning the system
you're playing with and you you said it
yourself you didn't realize that people
would be doing these character
assassinations yeah and i was saying
with my first business i didn't
understand the system in which you build
a business in hiring and all these
things so yeah you can reflect on it and
say oh naivety right right
right but then what happens next
so for me next i
i said well i'm not going back to that
private sector job that i hated i'm
gonna have to deal with being broke
and
what are all and i loved
i loved meeting people on the campaign
trail i loved talking to them i loved
hearing about
their problems
and
i i'm still that 13 year old girl who
wants to make a difference in the world
still the the dharma warrior
and i was like okay what of all the
things i saw on the campaign trail what
moved me
and you know when i ran for office it
was in 2010 so it was when tech was
starting to boom twitter was just coming
up facebook instagram
and i would go into computer science
classrooms and robotics labs and i would
just see lines and lines and lines of
boys
trying to be the next steve jobs or mark
zuckerberg and because i wasn't a coder
or computer scientist
i was like where are the girls where are
the people of color
and i kept thinking about those
classrooms
and so then i spent the next year
basically on my lunch breaks and in my
evenings just learning everything about
why there weren't girls and women in
coding
and started kind of writing a business
plan
that became grocery code and started
plotting my next
run
so i basically ended up running for
public advocate of new york city which
is kind of like the second position to
mayor
and then launching girls who code at the
same time
that's a lot to have on one's plate
it was
would you recommend that
well the way it played out i would
recommend it because
i
it all ended up working out good for
girls who code because i lost the public
advocates race was about i'm gonna make
sure that every kid in new york city
learns how to code
i lose that race
this time i realized wow like politics
is just it's not like i like to say it's
not a performance sport it's not a
meritocracy it's not like the person
with the best ideas
wins and now i've
run you know one i've taught 20 girls to
code
uh and so now i'm like all right if
you're not going to elect me i'm still
going to teach every girl to code i'm
going to teach every girl in america to
code and then the world
and then i really have a chip on my
shoulder because now i didn't get picked
for the first draft i didn't get picked
for the second draft either
and you use those skills right so you've
learned a bunch of skills along the way
and this is one of the blessings of
failure you get to learn all of these
wonderful skills about the nature of the
world and people and fundraising and i'm
guessing in in many ways that was
failure had been a blessing because
without those two
draft misses
you wouldn't have all these amazing
skills you have now right totally i
think the biggest skill that i learned
in being in campaigning is how do you
tell a story
how do you inspire people
how do you
connect to people
and you know by my second campaign i
don't have the written out speech in my
pocket i don't have the suit on i got my
hoops and my red lipstick
and i i can i am communicating and i'm
there and i'm present
and i have nothing to prove
and you know i don't i fight back when
people do the character assassination
i'm not easily convinced when people say
that they're going to support me that
they're going to really support me like
i can see people now
and so i lose that race but you're right
i learn so much and i become
more comfortable in my skin in who i am
and girls who code really phenomenal
thing um i read that you've reached
over almost half a million girls with
right
is that half a million girls that have
learned to code
that is crazy that we've actually gone
through our coding programs and then
we've reached about a half a billion
through our work our books our videos
our campaigns
we've reached a lot of kids
tell me about this organization how does
it look how does it function is it how
is it distributed all over the world i i
read that there's 1 500 girls who code
clubs around the world
yeah well there's 10 there was 10 000 so
10 yeah a lot and in the uk there's 10
000. 10 000 girls record well so it
started like
basically the model was
when i started girls with code
point four percent of girls were
interested in coding
and girls were interested in making the
world a better place but when they
thought about a computer scientist they
thought about some guys sitting in the
basement somewhere drinking a red bull
and they were like yeah no thank you
and we just culturally had done such a
good job of pushing girls and people of
color out of technology you know we had
barbie dolls that said i hate math let's
go shopping instead every image that you
saw on television you know from weird
science to revenge of the nerds was just
again these like really nerdy
white dudes
and so it didn't feel very inclusive and
so girls who code you know are what i
wanted to do is one meet girls where
they were at
and two change the culture and so what i
mean by me girls where they're at i
started thinking well if girls went to
technology companies
like a facebook
or a spotify and they walked in and they
saw what was happening they actually
learned to code embedded in a classroom
inside a tech company
and that the project while they were
there was to build something about a
change that they wanted to make again
connecting it to what girls wanted to do
then i can then inspire a generation of
young women to want to be
coders and technologists
and so we started kind of one tech
company at a time and we would build
these summer camps and you know years
you know basically you know in a handful
of years we're running kind of the
largest
summer camp you know in america
and then we started expanding that
and then you know part of
you know as an organizer i wasn't really
a you know i wasn't building a nonprofit
i was building a movement
and what i would say to my students i
would say okay
and the experience for them was
transformative i mean it was just you
saw these girls just
explode in terms of like what they
wanted to do their the sisterhood that
they built and every classroom was
basically you know
white asian black trans non-binary just
and so many girls had never met you know
girls who were white and never met
someone who was black before never been
friends with somebody who was trans so
like you were basically creating
quite frankly what the world should look
like in terms of love and empathy and
sisterhood and so
i would say you know during the
graduation i want to ask from you
i want you to go back to your community
and i want to go back to your school and
i want you to start a club and i want
you to find one girl that's going to
join
and so they like met me on my challenge
and so then one girl and then 100 girls
and then we ended up with 10 000 girls
who code clubs across the country in
every single county town in paris and
then we exploded in india and in the uk
and
same model right where you had
basically girls going back to their
communities volunteers librarians
teachers people saying i want to start i
want to start this i want to build to
help you build this move but i want to
start this club
and so we just had this massive
explosion and then culturally
we started slowly slowly slowly changing
the narrative and making coding cool you
know last year we did a partnership with
dogecat you know where we basically
coated her nails literally in one day
steven a hundred thousand girls signed
on to the website to basically learn how
to code nails
and now ten years later you know you
turn on netflix and you watch any teen
drama which i love to watch
you know the the protagonist is always a
cool girl coder and so we've made coding
cool we've built the pipeline of talent
you talked about the hardships you
encountered on the campaign trail cat
character assassination yes the anxiety
of it dealing with failure
business is riddled with the same
inevitable hardships so tell me in in
building girls who code
tell me about the other side
which is the
the difficult parts
well i mean one i didn't know what i was
doing you know and and like i'd never
built a large-scale organization like
that and so
you know i i had one of the good things
was that i had a board that believed in
me always build your first board as
family and friends because everybody
then is um
wanting you to succeed
and so
they really protected me like i am
i'm intense
and and and if you're gonna come work
for me you know it's gonna be intense
and so intense
uh i you know i don't i don't i'm better
now
but
i'm gonna ask your employees yeah i'm
better now but
i got big vision and i want to get it
done
and i work and all the time
and i don't stop
and it's it's i'm always pushing
and i believe in many ways i'm an
evangelist
and i believe in so it is it is my
gospel grosser quote was my life my
gospel my religion
and so i think if you're going to come
work for me it's your religion too
i heard you're the passion filter
girls who code
i do have a passion filter yeah yeah but
you but then but then when you become a
thousand
people you know you you or you know 100
you know like you it's hard you're not
going to get everybody who's going to
have that same passion and that same
intensity do you struggle with that when
people don't
seem to
well when they don't behave in the way
that you would have behaved in that
situation or when they don't seem to
have the same passion and
you know
that you you have yeah i don't believe
in jobs
but for some people it's a job
um but i don't believe in i don't
believe in jobs um so when when so that
that i've you know what do they say you
have the triangle right you have you
have a people every organization has top
a people and then b and then c's and
then these but you need to have a couple
of cs maybe not d's right
and so and also like i was just telling
you about my father
that sent me the 10 page email or you
know about all the things i did wrong i
wasn't good at great job
thank you for doing that
because
i was an event this was church this was
religion
you know and so i got i got better at
these things
you know one of the things i was always
good at though was hiring people who
were smarter than me i've never had an
ego
about like i want to be the one
and so
i had really amazing people from the
beginning who as they say knew how to
speak reshma
did you get the
praise criticism balance wrong
i definitely got to praise criticism
i i definitely don't know
i still i i have to i get i'm better now
because i just send flowers
so it's like
um
you know what because i don't need it
and maybe i tell myself i don't need it
people don't say to me on a daily basis
good job
great work but you get it right because
you get it everywhere you go every time
they i mean you're on cnbc earlier on
right the way they introduce you is
you know it's this is what i'm just
thinking i'm answering this for myself
because i i was interrogating that from
my perspective no one ever says well
done to us in terms of our team right
really like in the same way there's no
but we get i get it if i open my dms on
instagram i get oh my god you you know
you do i do too but you know i'm gonna
tell you this
i stepped off a ceo a year ago because i
also never believe that anyone should do
anything for too long
and i had built the organization i had
the money in the bank
i had a vision i had an amazing
woman that i wanted to take
take the take the reins for me
and
the day we make the announcement
my my my chief of staff gloria is like
okay brush i'm going to block off
two to four
because you're going to get inundated
with so many messages
congratulating you thanking you
for your service
and i was like okay yes i'm ready for it
you know tree and i make the
announcement
nothing
and she emails me tarika emails me you
know at five being like oh my god you
must be over i'm so overwhelmed with all
the messages that i've gotten
congratulating me for being the new ceo
of grocery code you must also i didn't
want to make her feel back she's such a
wonderful person i was like yeah
nothing
and i realized at that moment because i
wasn't the head [ __ ] in charge anymore
right i wasn't the ceo anymore
and so i it was a wonderful the lesson a
little bit too about how much of that is
coming from
who you are
and how much of that is really this
i guess you don't know until you die
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast one of the
greatest tips i can give any small
business owner listening right now is to
take risks in fact the biggest risk to
your business will be taking two fewer
risks complacency and comfort seeking
will harm your success but taking risks
can be incredibly daunting that's why
i've partnered with vodafone business
and their vhub which offers free
one-to-one sessions with vhub digital
advisors and you can call up and speak
to one completely free of charge sharing
your ideas and getting input from
someone who's knowledgeable on the topic
and able to help you towards your next
business step to find out more search
v-hub by vodafone and thank you for
vodafone for sponsoring this podcast
so this big organization girls who code
all around the world
doing incredibly well what would you
have done differently
i would so i think what i got really
wrong was the personal
you know at the same time i was trying
to build girls who code i was trying to
have a baby
and i had more miscarriages than i can
count
and
i got into this habit
at girls who code you know very again so
you know i launched girls who code i'm
launching my campaign i have my first
miscarriage and i think when you have
your first miscarriage you you think oh
is this a fluke
and then i had a series of them
but i would literally you know then i'm
heads down building girls who code and
again i think when you are a social
entrepreneur and you're building
something the work is never done and
it's always at the sacrifice of others
and you always are giving giving giving
giving
and i would get into i got into this
habit where
you know i'd have to go to the doctor's
office my husband and i for the
11 12 week check-in
and i'd have something planned in the
evening introducing president obama
speaking to a thousand girls doing a
fundraising dinner
and
the doctor at three o'clock would say
i'm sorry mr johnny you know
we don't hear a heartbeat
and
instead of saying
hey guys i can't show up
i'd say okay
i cry my husband be like rushmo go home
and i'd be like i gotta show up at this
thing
and i'd show up
and i would
did that
for seven years six years seven years
where it just and i would remember we
would stand there in front of the crowd
and be like something's wrong with me
the fact that i can do this
and i would be often times standing in
front of a
thousand little girls the little girl
that i desperately wanted
and
and so
it wasn't until
you know i think when it became too much
of the way that i was leading and living
and you know by the time after i had my
first and the second my second child the
same pattern started becoming i remember
this one time i got i was in san
francisco and i had to go fly to utah
and
same thing you know doctor calls and
says you know uh you know your levels
don't look good you're gonna miscarry
soon
um
and i got on that plane to utah and i
had to sit down with the governor of
utah and again another thousand girls
and then i just broke down and i
remember i assembled my team and i said
i i
i can't do this anymore
like i i i i
i'm taking
a couple months off for a month off i
need you to run this organization
this is what is happening in my life and
has been happening
you know every picture every ted talk
every every and when i look at me
standing with president obama or the ted
talk i think about the tragedy or the
baby that was quite frankly dying inside
of me and so for me i got that really
wrong
really wrong
and um
i don't want people and and part of what
i'm grateful for
is
people didn't know because you know i'm
also in the responsibility of a lot of
young women who work for me
and i don't want them to think that
that's the price that you have to pay
what advice would you give people to
avoid them hitting because you've hit a
rock bottom moment multiple times in
your life through like unsustainable
behavior right yeah that's how i see it
so what advice would you give to people
who
are probably veering towards another
rock bottom in their lives because
they're not listening to themselves i
guess
well i mean i think the thing is is that
i think
many of us live in this i don't like
up and then crash
right and that's what we think is the
way that you're supposed to live and i
think you need to live always
healthy meaning like you have to put
your personal mental health and your
personal health
first
and so don't wait for rock bottom to hit
you know see the signs early on and take
those breaks take that time off
you know take a nap whatever whatever it
is that you need to do don't live
in that same way anymore
but it's hard because again the entire
girl boss culture
the entire kind of lean in culture
the entire you know ceo culture is about
living that way it's almost like a badge
of honor hey i had you know no heartbeat
and i went gave speech
like that's almost like what we think
we're supposed to do
uh
to to lead that's strength
and i think we have to completely revise
what that means and what it means to be
a leader and it means you know empathy i
i too you know was leading girls who
during the pandemic
and had to lay off a bunch of people and
until that point i had never cried in
front of my team and i would just cry
and cry
and then i would get mad at myself for
about crying but then i think no no
that's exactly what you're supposed to
do
you're supposed to cry you're supposed
to show vulnerability you're supposed to
say hey guys i just got some incredibly
horrible news i i'm not coming to work
but that's often seen as a sign of
weakness and we have to make that a sign
of strength
i'm guessing your book brave not perfect
was written in this period of your life
oh yes right yeah because there's many
things you regret about that book yeah
because i think that book was also about
corporate feminism about fixing the
woman
and not fixing the structure and look i
acknowledge that in the book
that you know but what i what i used to
say is you know while we're fixing the
institutions let's figure out how we can
fix ourselves you know i.e you know
unlearning perfectionism and orientating
yourself towards bravery but i really
believe that stephen you know i really
bought into that
um that i that we could get to equality
you know that it was really about the
power pose you know and the color coding
of your calendar and the delegating more
and then not crying in the bathroom and
all the things that you were supposed to
do
to be a leader and i think that's what
women have been told and so we were
never looking at well what's wrong
with the structure why in for example
going back to my experience i was
telling you about fertility you know why
do we do performance reviews and not
wellness reviews
why are you not supposed to be sad at
work why are you not supposed to cry
you know where did we where did these
values
show up and how do we get them out
written on the back of your new book
which takes
a very different approach on many
narratives
rachelle simmons says
finally we have a book that aims to fix
the system not the women
and i think when i was reading about why
you wrote this book pay up the future of
women and work
i read that you wrote it from a place of
on one hand anger but also hope for
change yeah
why anger
well listen i mean i
i as a mom you know found myself
20 20 uh you know
started the year with girls who code
having a super bowl ad i was going to
teach more girls than i ever had before
i was having my second baby finally
you know via surrogate and so i was
really looking forward to once i was
born just spending that time with him
and just hugging him and kissing him and
staring at him because i had missed
carrying him in the womb
and then you know a few weeks later the
pandemic hit
and i found myself having to take care
of my newborn homeschool my six-year-old
and save my non-profit girls who crowd
from being shut down
because when pandemics hit the first
resources to go are to women and girls
you know my whole leadership team were
both mostly working women and what we
were saying to each other on the zoom
chat was just just hold on
hold on because when september comes
and the school's open
everything will be fine
and i remember that when that september
came and i got that letter from our
department of education my son goes to
public school in new york city
they announced this thing called you
know hybrid learning where you got to
log on your kid at nine o'clock 10
o'clock and eleven o'clock
all the while maintaining your full-time
job
i thought two things came to my mind
the first one which was incredibly naive
like aren't they gonna ask me
because you know in the united states we
have these time and use surveys and so
we knew
in the early months of the pandemic
who was doing the homeschooling
it was women
and so we knew that if we made a policy
like closing down the schools
that it was in invariably going to force
millions of women to leave the workforce
because they couldn't supplement you
know their their paid labor they were
going to have to supplement their paid
labor for unpaid labor
and so the fact that someone that i
don't even know
could make a decision that could affect
my life on a dime
terrified me
and then the second thing was you
started seeing again over the course of
the pandemic 11 million women leave the
workforce
and i knew from building girls who code
because you know girls of code i was
trying to solve the gender gap in
technology but what people forget is
that we didn't always have a gender
reaction technology that in the 1980s we
were pretty much almost at parity and
then we pushed women out and so
similarly here you can't have women be
51 of the labor force and then become
you know in the 40s again percent of the
labor force and have all those women
leave in nine months and think that it's
an on and off switch
so i remember like where's the plan
like
is the president going to get on and
announce the plan that we're going to
have to make sure that
we don't devastate
decades of feminism and so there was no
plan
and that's what really inspired me to
start this moment i wrote an op-ed i
often stephen when i get angry write
and then just post things post articles
and um
i made the mistake or actually it was
the best thing that ever happened is i
read the comment section
and my op-ed was that we need a martial
plan for moms
and when i read the comment section
people on the left were like what about
the dads
and i was like even though again
men had not been pushed out of the labor
force because this was from a data
perspective
solely affecting women
and then people on the right well mother
has a choice
so you don't get to have affordable
child care or paid leave or any
structural support because you choose
you chose to be a mom
and it was the first time i was like wow
motherhood
is controversial
and i kind of had that same sense that i
had when i started girls who code like
this is a problem
that needs solving again especially for
women like
our mothers
you know my mom when she when i was a
kid
um
i was a latchkey kid from the time i was
seven
and my parents couldn't afford the fifty
dollars a week for child care
and so from the time my sister and i
were seven and ten she would pick me up
from middle school
and we would go home now remember i told
you that we lived in this neighborhood
that didn't really want any brown
families there so we wouldn't walk home
we would run home
and then we would open up the door and
close it and we would hide in the closet
because we were terrified
and i think about how my mother felt
every day at 3 45
knowing that her babies were running
home
because they couldn't afford
child care and the unconscionable
choices
that mothers mothers of color have to
make every single
day
because we don't make it possible for
them
to be mothers and have a job
and so that is when i was just like
all of this
girl boss
equality that expressed me into the
corner office it's just all about you
was like
that's a lie
and i've been selling this lie for the
past 10 years
and if we're really going to get to
equality we have to fix the systems
there's a really staggering stat in um
chapter 4 of your book that
says that women are now spending more
time on child care than they did in i
think it was 1980
which is pretty staggering because i i
thought we'd
one would think based on all the noise
that i've heard about equality and all
of these things that
women would be spending less time on
child care than 1980. yeah it's because
we're in this moment of intensive
parenting think about our my parents
didn't even know where i applied to
college they didn't know what i was
doing at homework it was just like go
raise yourself right
now you know we're taking our kids to
spanish hindi and you know
and you know chinese you're learning
three languages going to piano class you
know basketball club
we're constantly on top of our kids
because that is the societal expectation
that we have to intensively parent our
children at the expense of our own
mental health and we also have to be
completely on as workers again we're in
this hustle culture where you're
constantly driving driving driving you
know
at work and so if you're a working woman
you have these two huge expectations
that that you basically have to meet and
it's exhausting and it's why we have a
mental health crisis you know 51 of
mothers say that they're anxious and
depressed
you know the cdc released the studies
saying that the subgroup that is
suffering the most anxiety and
depression are you know working women
you're seeing this in the uk it's an
alcoholism adderall addiction it is on
the rise rising suicide rates of mothers
mothers don't break
but they're broken right now
and young people feel like they can
easily talk about their mental health
and how they're feeling and but it is
it's not again you don't
you don't hear mothers talk about that
we're not supposed to we're supposed to
be martyrs essentially or have it all
together
and so there's no outlet for us
you know i say in my book when when
working women make a list it's like
their kids you know their partner their
pet and then themselves
we are last on the list
we do no self-care and in our and
society
doesn't you know doesn't expect that we
we should be doing that it's seen as
being a bad mom or being selfish when we
spend time on ourselves
how is your mental health
i i would i would say that i am a
i would say that i am a six
right now i mean i'm exhausted i'm not
gonna lie i think i'm i think that i
think that
i think i have you know two little kids
now two and seven
um you know the pandemic has been
crushing
you know my seven-year-old
eats his clothes because he's anxious
you know my two-year-old you know can't
talk yet you know he's got asthma you
know he gets sick all the time because
now the mask has come out and now his
son doesn't you know his brother doesn't
have one so he's getting sick so so you
know our kids have really been
traumatized
because of the pandemic and now we're
traumatized
and so
i do think that like
and i think a lot of the
the the women in my life
i think would just need a beat
like i wish they would announce like a
national vacation for like a month
maybe that's the answer to the question
i was compelled to ask next but how
would you get yourself if you were to
give yourself advice if i just told you
what you told me i was the six what
advice would you give me to get to a ten
i would say uh
take a break
you know or do things for yourself and
listen i think i'm much better at that
so i got
one of the best things i got for myself
was a whoop
yeah
so i'm like obsessed about my sleep
and to the extent that i will go to bed
at 8 a.m or leave a dinner early
um because i know that if i'm getting
eight hours of sleep
i am my best version
i try to play tennis three times a week
i love tennis i'm horrible at it but i
love it
you know i
try to have fun i went to a justin
bieber concert last weekend you know i
do date night i got girls trips planned
uh i i i make more time for myself i
don't i don't get on but you know
basically for 10 years as i was building
girls who code i would probably do two
to three flights a week
and then trying to take the red eyes to
be home for my babies and i don't do
that anymore you know i say no
i realize that like
it's not that this opportunity is going
to go away
i didn't realize that before you know
what i mean i was like i gotta do this i
gotta show up here i gotta
but no it's like
maybe i won't get this chance again but
oh well
and it's really liberating
and so i think the only reason why i'm a
sixth question is i'm in the middle of a
book tour and so i've definitely been
orientating more towards old reshma of
like you know three four talks a day
getting on planes doing the thing not
sleeping as much eating too many
chocolate chip cookies like but i think
my my habits
and have been much more healthier than
they've ever been i'm also really
practicing um
not wanting things
i
i think growing up as an immigrant i
needed credentials
i needed val i needed those degrees i
needed that validation
i needed those accolades
and i was always chasing the next
big thing
and it's funny as i sit here there's
nothing i want
there's no title i want
there's no award i want there's no
recognition i want
and when i start
catching myself
wanting things
uh i pull back
you know i told you i was just i applied
to yale law school three times before i
got in
and i got a call last november from the
president of yale saying
um
we would be honored if you'd be our
commencement speaker
now steven like the commencement
speakers are normally like hillary brock
you know what i mean
and then of course my friends were like
the real one my husband's like the real
one i was like yes the real one
but it was so
amazing
one getting that because that i had been
chasing them for so long and finally
they
they asked me
but two it was um
exactly i wasn't chasing it
a few questions there
in terms of getting putting up those
boundaries and getting good at saying no
is there now like a i think as we age we
develop a prism in which our decisions
filter through
which allows us to decide whether this
is serving us or not like when you're
younger you just say yes to everything
so
some guy with
i don't know radio station no one's
listening to wants to interview you go
oh my god someone wants to interview yes
i will fly twice tell me where yeah
exactly yeah right but then as you
realize the importance of time and that
every decision you're saying yes you
comes at the expense of something else
is that what is your prism now where you
find yourself in your career
when you're deciding what to say yes or
no to so two things i think one impact
yeah and two i love
listen i love people who are starting up
and who i know that if i go on their
podcast
or if i
if i have them interview me
i will be the most famous guest that
they have and it will help them i want i
like to be that person and sometimes my
team will big rush you don't have time
to do something no no these are the ones
that are actually
the most important to me
um
and because someone did that for me and
that's how i'm sitting here with you
today
and then i think the other i again i
think going back i've been um
i've been studying the bhagavad-gita
uh which has again been
a gift i gave myself this year because
it's been something i've been wanting to
do for a long time
the gita is basically our kind of
religious book in hinduism but it's
really a you know it's really a it's
really a book about
spirituality and about how do you
stay really focused
um on what you're meant to do in this
earth and not get distracted by all the
shiny things
and and that's really important to me as
i kind of enter this final the stage of
my life
of i again staying very focused
on what i'm on this earth to do
and not getting distracted by all the
shiny things and one thing that kita
says is like it doesn't make sense that
human wants that humans want things
because all you're doing is inviting
yourself for disappointment
right if you didn't want anything
you don't get it
doesn't matter because you never wanted
it
and and so um you know that has been
a really big gift for me
in really staying focused because if i'm
put on this earth to be a warrior
and my job right now is to fight for
mothers to get them respected and
dignified and to change workplaces you
know so that they work for women and
that this is the once opportunity to
make that structural change then
everything i'm saying yes to is about
furthering
that
my service for the people
in your book you talk about that change
and you kind of list four sort of key
principles for bringing about that
change empower educate revise and advert
advocate
tell me about empower what did you mean
when you wrote that in in your book yeah
so look i mean empower's really about
like women are always told like you
should just meditate more or do yoga and
if you do that you'll feel really good
and so i didn't want to take those kind
of
dated you know again fix the woman stuff
but really what are some like
non-negotiables and so one of the things
i talk about in the book is this idea of
creating tangible boundaries
and so like in my house you know my
husband does the nights and i do the
mornings
and if i'm sitting around watching
netflix that's sick so big hey can you
change a diaper can you warm up with a
bottle
so at six o'clock i just bounce
i go for dinner by myself
you know i go out with my friends i walk
but i'm just my point is i'm gone
and so i've created that
boundary
um so that i don't get roped into doing
more of that unpaid labor
than i need to and so i think that the
the need to create boundaries for all of
us that's really critical
you know the second piece is really
about how are we shifting
employers
i am literally just like i was with
girls i am on a mission to get companies
to start subsidizing child care
you know in the united states and then
in the world you know in the u.s you
know child care is like the largest
expense for families most families pay
more for child care than they pay for
their mortgage
and right now less than 10 percent of
companies subsidize child care we often
think of child care as your personal
problem
but child care is an economic issue
and so i am you know building this
national business coalition to get
companies to start paying for people's
child care they pay for people's egg
freezing and ivf they should be paying
when you take care you know i mean when
you have a child and so how are we
shifting again this idea of you know
what employers should be doing you know
it's women's it was women's history
month last last month and so many of the
conversations we were having you know
probably you know again across across
the country across the world is about
you know you should get a mentor you
should get a sponsor all of the
programming that we do around women's
empowerment is about fixing women
it needs to be about fixing workplaces
you know why don't companies offer child
care
why don't companies mandate paid leave
for men
so that when you're again doing child
caring childbearing from the beginning
you get the ratio right you get the
equation right why are we still fighting
flexibility in remote working why are we
still trying to demand that men and
women commute two hours
and not see their children or their pets
or their elderly parents
you know why are we resisting again
you know what we've learned from the
pandemic and forcing ourselves back to
the old normal and how do we push
against this
you know and again shift corporate
policies um the third thing i talk about
in this book is about you know how do
you revise the culture
you know again it's so normal for women
for example you know to hide their
motherhood i remember when i became a
mom and my team was like great like you
should be a mom blogger i'm like no
anything but a mom
you know moms are seen as like you know
again you know when you become a mother
you're seen as like you don't no longer
care about your career it's like where
you go to die
and i think we have to start shifting
that and we have to start parenting out
loud
you know you shouldn't be hiding your
kids from your workplace you shouldn't
be apologizing when your kids interrupt
your zoom call you shouldn't be waiting
to the last possible second to say that
you're pregnant because you're worried
that your employer is going to
discriminate against you you know we
have to really start parenting out loud
and being honest about
about that you know you go on instagram
and you see pictures of mothers and
their kids and they're all beautiful and
they're wearing matching outfits that's
not what vacations look like you know my
vacation everyone's fighting with each
other and we're screaming tell the truth
about what it looks like you know and
that's how we begin to shift
i think the cultural image of motherhood
and we shift from being martyrs
you know to being respected and to being
valued
but like you know again i think i think
motherhood needs a refresh
um across the world and then and then
finally it's really about advocating for
change you know we just went through you
know in in the u.s
you know we just went through the
president kind of proposing policies and
nothing got changed we didn't get you
know united is one of the only nations
that doesn't have paid leave
you know we don't have affordable child
care
in the uk you have a parental income we
don't have those things you know and so
we need to really make structural change
that comes
from the government to really make
laughter lasting change and we
you know as working women have to learn
how we fight for ourselves you know we
have so many movements that are about
protecting our kids you know mothers
against drunk driving mothers who are
marching against
you know gun reform mothers that are
trying to protect the climate but there
isn't a movement of mothers fighting for
moms
you know i tell people all the time you
can't change the lives of girls unless
you change the future of women
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
as you look forward at your
your mission and your future
and uh what you hope to
achieve
in the next chapter of your life what is
that tangibly if i had to measure
success if i was to say that your your
you know all the things you write about
the change you write about in this book
if i was to measure and say it was
successful what what what would the
world look like
that we have true equality
you know that that little girls can be
everything and anything honestly
you know that they can be president or
prime minister that they can launch a
company you know and get seed funding
that they can be a scientist that they
can literally or they can be a
stay-at-home mom
that they can be whoever and whatever
that they want
and i think my hope for mothers is that
they too don't see their their their
biggest dreams die on the vine
that they don't live a life of regret
and envy and should have been would have
been because they let every they let
things happen to them
rather than change things uh that we
live in a world where we we respect and
we dignify
women and girls we're not there yet
you know we're so we're so far from
being there
in many ways and and i think part of it
again is because
of the things that we've sold women that
we've we've basically told women that
the problem is you
think about all the books that women
read confidence code i gotta learn how
to do a power pose i gotta i gotta lean
in all of it is about women thinking
that you're wrong
the amount of times that women come to
me and say i have imposter syndrome i'm
like no no no they didn't let you in
you're in there because you are the best
but now you're made to feel like you
snuck through the back door
and so it it what you know what i am
saying in many ways is really radical
and it's you know very deeply seated in
us and it's not just it's women it's
people of color it's poor people anybody
who is
not you know who who has really you know
had to
had to through grit perseverance you
know found themselves in rooms that
people don't look like them
we're still asking ourselves do i belong
here should i be here
and we're constantly being fed
information book podcasts movies that
tell ourselves that we just have to
change one more thing about ourselves
that we have to fix one more thing
and you know it's just simply not true i
i always say that i feel so lucky
that you know
through the work that i've done i've
been able to be in almost every single
powerful room i've probably met every
single powerful person in the world
and you know i used to be that girl at
yale law school in my constitutional law
class going like this
and you know a few years ago i got asked
to give a speech
at bill gates summit
and the slot that they had given me
was between bill gates and warren
buffett
and it was the only speech that anyone
was giving it was a summon a fortune 100
ceo so you can imagine who was in the
room
and i remember them saying you know this
is a really hard speaking slot rashma
because most people are really
intimidated
because bill and warren are sitting in
the front row and it can be a little
scary
and i remember as i was sitting there in
the backstage they had given me 10
minutes of speech i remember thinking
man i wish they gave me 12
because i really had some more stuff to
say
and then i remember thinking how did i
become
[Music]
how did i become this woman
when i used to be that
girl
and i remember thinking yeah it's
because i've been in every single
powerful room i've met every single ceo
every president every prime minister and
when i meet them i'm like you
you're running what
me and my girls we can run circles
around you
and i realize that it's never been about
whether we're qualified whether we're
prepared
whether we're
ready that we've really never really
dissected all of the undeserved unearned
privilege that so many people have
and that we have literally bought and
been fed
you know
basically this propaganda
that we're not good enough that we're
not smart enough that we don't belong
and the real resistance
in this moment is saying no more i'm not
reading those books i'm not taking those
courses
i'm not taking that class i'm not buying
into that [ __ ]
i'm here
and i can lead to
that's a very powerful place to end
however we do have a closing tradition
okay
where the previous guest writes the
question for the next guest oh my gosh
okay and i don't get to see
you don't get to find out who it is and
i don't get to read it to open this book
amazing jack is the only person that
gets to read it when was the last time a
day flew by and what were you doing
you know one of those days
i don't know if i've had a day but i've
definitely had a couple hours
and i think the last time was i actually
got to visit
my son's school for the very first time
in the pandemic
and my son is a little gandhi he is like
the kindest little soul
and just being able to watch him
and him show me his things and just
seeing him interact and the joy
and like the confidence and the kindness
and i could have sat there all day
and it felt like again a minute because
i think i was so happy
does he understand your work
he does he doesn't i mean he he does
understand or he's mad at me sometimes
why are you always fighting for girls
and moms what about the boys
but uh
you know it's funny i i brought i would
bring him everywhere you know from
being on the daily show or giving a
commencement speech and so he's seen
mama
lead and and speak and he knows that i'm
helping people and i think it's in many
ways it i think it has he always said
that he wants to be a kindness engineer
that he wants to you know
be an engineer to to help people
and maybe get hopefully i'm going to
take credit for that a little bit
because i think he sees that uh you know
in the work that i do
but
but yeah he's he is um he's an old soul
thank you um i have to say you know
it's it's really it's really a
tremendous thing and it's really
inspiring the thought that you've
managed to get
almost half a million girls into
coding it really really inspires me in a
deep level because i've been thinking
about
work that i want to do in my life and so
reading through your story was a real
source of inspiration specifically
around i've been thinking a lot about
because i'm an investor on the show
called dragons den in the uk um been
thinking a lot about how
young kids from disadvantaged
backgrounds don't know how to invest
their money don't know about taxes and
all those kinds of things and seeing the
model of
girls who code and how you've managed to
reach so many people
on a topic that is liberating if people
can understand it in the same way that
understanding money is liberating if you
can truly understand it
has been is a blueprint for me and
that's why i was so excited to meet you
and your your book is really fantastic
thank you one of those books that leaves
you with a real sense of mission and
inspiration and really makes you take
stock of your life and and the future of
the industry we we all reside in in the
working world it's also made me consider
a lot of changes that i need to make in
my own companies even this conversation
we've had today because i as a male ceo
and male ceos are the dominant force at
the top of organizations they are the
the most um
abundant
uh creature in organizations especially
the fortune 500 white male ceos
in particular
can't understand a lot of these things
because they haven't had the lived
experience and even when they say they
understand all the time it's either
virtue signaling to protect the bottom
line or something else and having forces
like you in the world that are that are
able to articulate
this systemic challenge in such an
articulate way is more necessary now
than ever before so thank you for being
you and thank you for writing a book
that i feel everybody needs to read pay
up the future of women and work thank
you
quick one as we all know energy
independence and living a little greener
has never been more important for a
better future it's a journey i've been
on over the last couple of years that
i've shared with you sporadically ever
since i sold my range rover sport and
bought an electric bicycle and there's a
lot of people out there that listen to
this podcast that are looking to make
that sustainable switch in
the things that run their daily life
whether it's their home their car their
vehicles whatever it might be so when a
good friend of mine at a company called
my energy called jordan told me she was
interested in sponsoring this podcast i
jumped at the opportunity so for those
of you that don't know my energy are a
uk renewable energy brand whose mission
is to increase the usage of green energy
helping people like you and i to save
time and money when it comes to making
sustainable switches in our lives so if
this resonates with you and you're the
type of person that's been looking or
thinking about going on your own
sustainability journey i highly
recommend checking them out at
myenergy.com
quick one as the seasons have begun to
change so has my diet and um
right now i'm just gonna be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad and so one of the things i'm
doing now to reduce my calorie intake
and trying to get back to being
nutritionally complete and all i eat is
i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
[Music]
you